angel yes angel where you grow up from
Persia originally from the harbor area
San Pedro California I was born in
Torrance raised in San Pedro and some of
you are there no actually I didn't my
mom and my dad separated when I was
young and it was I don't know the
reasons they did separate up to this day
I don't know but I do know that living
around two years old I was I guess my
dad had tricked me from my mom and
somehow we ended up in San Jose
California but this time my mom got me
back mind you I was a toddler I was only
two years old I had a third-degree burn
on the top of my head and the story was
that up to this day that I still you
know here is that I had grabs a pot from
the stove but I'm 2 years old how can I
reach the stove and I still have to
start on the top of my head but it's
shrank throughout the years I'm 52 years
old now so 50 years ago but it's still
the scars a little bit that it scarred
me it scarred you from from that day
because I've always had a conflict about
it um like I said I don't know what
really happened
my mom don't know we really don't know
what happened but my mom got me back
they separated sometime after that and
then my mom remarried again and that was
another story that you know they were
they nothing happy nothing nothing that
I never you know I could even think of
it has yeah you know happy part in my
entire life but you learn to deal with
situations and um you like we need to
accept it or you know you could try to
change it and I've tried to do both
eventually I started growing up I was 17
16 17 when I left home
I left home by myself came out to the LA
area and I went from one crowd to
another big transgender since I've been
like 13 and they I think you know
they've always known it so that even
made it double harder on me they all my
family are gang members from my mom to
my dad so all my uncles they're all gang
members from the Hartford area so that
was double rough on me so I've grown up
around a lot of violence and like I said
you know I've always trying to make it
even a good situation out of a bad one
but somehow you know I wasn't just I
didn't have that luck so I did leave
home I left home and I just try to
change you know something that I felt
that maybe could be better for me if I
separated from all of them it wasn't all
good you know I have moments that I can
say that you know ok well this wasn't
too bad but who's to say that it's not
too bad for one person when it could be
for another oh yeah there was big time
my stepfather when my mom had remarried
that's when one of the reasons I had
left home when my mom had remarried and
she ended up having my sister first and
her name was one eek then she turned
around she had my brother Jacob and
there was abuse throughout the whole
their whole relationship and it was
always focused on me I have a older
brother my mom would always take him and
somehow I held her accountable for that
because I felt like you know maybe she
knew what was going on because of the
situation was you know my sexuality they
all knew what was gonna happen you know
I didn't understand it I was young I was
too young to me I've always been a girl
but you know when you have somebody keep
pounding it into you know you're a boy
you're a boy it becomes a problem
mentally so from one day to another I
would have my clothes taken from me
thrown in the trash because they didn't
like them clothes
was wearing cuz I never dunk I wouldn't
you know find my stuff in the trash and
I would go take it out I'll go take it
out of the trash you know you know put
it back I put it back and she would turn
around my mom would tell me you can't be
acting up you're gonna get in trouble I
remember one time I had turned around
and I had these pair of shorts I was 12
years old and I'll never forget that
you know to me to me I've always been
like I said I believed that I was a girl
so anytime that they seen that I was
doing something out of my character that
they felt that wasn't you know boyish I
would be punished for it it went from
standing in the corner from 15 minutes
maybe to an hour and the more that I
rebelled and I didn't go along with what
they wanted me to do the longer I was in
there then it went from that's a
physical and my mom mom is that question
didn't know but she knew she knew what
was going on and you know I went from
that to just arguments between them
because of me because I wouldn't you
know keep my mouth shut and I wouldn't
you know do the things that they wanted
me to do and I never wanted my hair cut
because of that burn that I had on the
top of my head when they turn around
when they turned around and they told me
that they were gonna cut my hair off
intentionally I ran away from home for
the first time when I ran home away from
home I was gone for two weeks the first
time the second time I left home was
about three weeks to a month and they
found him I stepped out I don't know how
he found me but he went to my friend's
house where I was that he kicked her
durian he went straight through the
whole house looking for me found me in
the kitchen he grabbed me by my throat
he stabbed me up against the
refrigerator and
I'm 12 I don't know the difference I
don't know you know what I did wrong I
know is that I didn't want to be there I
tried to accept things you know for what
they are some things you could change
some things you can but he took me home
with him and my mom and him argued for a
couple of days they weren't kept going
on and on and on and I tell her every
time I had a chance I was gonna leave
and I wasn't gonna come back so finally
I don't know what my mom I don't know
what was words and my mom's hit at that
time but I know it was affecting her too
and I remember her she had a little 20
22 or 25 gun that she kept in her drawer
and I remembered I didn't go to school
that day
and I seen her chasing him down the
stairs we didn't do these apartments in
Montebello and she chased him down the
street just shooting the gun and she
called my uncles to come get us in they
came to get a daughters and we never
went back to the Omani bail after that
was my father I'm not sure I don't know
like I said I don't know what really
happened I don't know why you know he
did the things that he did to me I don't
know why him and my mom separated from
the beginning I don't know why he took
me and he didn't take my other my older
brother because I don't know nothing
like him I don't look nothing like my
mother a little bit like my mother but
not too much my father I don't look
nothing like him but I look like his
sister a little bit I resemble her a
little bit um like I said I've always
you know there's always those those you
wanna know you know could it have not
have why why me you know I've been to a
lot like I said throughout the years and
it's always been something tragic or
it's always been something that you know
we're good memories and I still have
those so when I finally left home at 16
after all that happened you know I felt
you know maybe if I just go somewhere on
my own that I can start fresh where
nobody knew me
you know be me I wouldn't have to you
know try to you know hide who I was even
though I was in hiding and I was me
really you know I just I didn't care I
didn't care what anybody said you know
I've always felt if I can't be myself
and accept me for who I am how is
anybody else gonna accept me but still I
went to a lot of issues a lot of trials
and tribulations I went through a lot of
hard times a lot of hard times and even
though you know I tried to make things
work they didn't work out for me either
way
I'm at 16 when I left home I came back
towards the LA area and I stood out here
I didn't monami Park for like maybe a
year or so with some of my friends that
I had from when I was younger and then I
started getting into trouble um my name
was never easy you know I've never
really had a real job except for maybe
two of them that they got rid of me
because I lied about my age I was
underage so they had to let me go so I
went from one thing to another then
prostitution came in it seemed that it
was easy money that's always something
that they you know that not all people
but there's a I can say at least 85% of
the guys that I meet it always has
something to do with something sexual
and I've learned to come to accept that
you know either I accept it or you know
I'm just going to be miserable my whole
life's learned to adapt and work with
who and what I am this is you know
there's no easy way to say it so I
started working the streets I started
out in Imani first then it went from
that to doing federal crimes cashing
checks and whatnot and in the process of
me doing that I end up mom get into a
lot of altercations on the streets with
different individuals and they became
cases but I wasn't the one that I wasn't
the person that has started or I wasn't
there
you know I've always felt that I needed
to I needed to protect myself because if
I didn't protect myself nobody else was
nobody else has ever done anything for
me you know as far as that in any other
way they have it even to this day you
know it's always on angel angel angel
and you got this engine about that you
know and I don't mind helping people I'm
a very giving person but it you know it
comes to a point when it's everyday
everyday everyday everyday and you know
and then you really think about it these
people don't give a [ __ ] about me they
don't give a [ __ ] about me they don't
give a [ __ ] about themselves there's
just you know one object that they want
and that's just whatever they can get to
keep moving forward everybody's just you
know there will come up for them that's
all it is is to come up you know and
that's basically why everybody knows me
on here because I help a lot of people
if I have it I'll help him but it wasn't
always that easy for me either coming
down here when I first came down here
and that's jumping the gun cuz I before
I even came out here like I said I got
into trouble and I was doing federal
crimes and I was young I went to Hawaii
at the age of 17 going on 18 they sent
me to ye for the first ones from forgery
and why at that time like I said you
know transgenders in those years they
weren't really accepted you know when I
got there they didn't know what to do
with me they kept me in open dorm area
where they can keep an eye on me where
the window was right there friend I was
in the first bunk in the front part and
I can't say that I had an easy time in
there but it wasn't really that hard
like I said I learned how to adapt with
who I was and work with what I had which
was myself in my body you know so I made
it work for me instead of them harassing
me because I was you know different or I
was gay or whatever they wanted to lay
I had the majority of guys trying to
have sex with me but they weren't trying
to take it you know they were they were
being as friendly as possible to be you
know game-related
army people and I didn't just that you
know people just take advantage of me
but in the same token I knew what I was
doing because if I didn't learn how to
use you know section with my sexuality
to move forward with people then somehow
they were just gonna step on me and I
was just going to becoming just another
statistic gonna be swept under the rug
so I learned how to work with that I
started prostituting at 16 and it went
from there to being um pretty much you
know just an open book cover where
everybody knew that you know oh that's
angel right there you know oh don't mess
with her because she doesn't take no
[ __ ] but it wasn't even about that you
know I'm not I'm not a hard person I'm
like I said I'm a very giving person but
people make you into who you are if you
let them and it became that for me
because instead of me just being you
know somebody that was sheltered and
somebody that didn't want you know all
the attention around me I had attention
drawn to me no matter what I did no
matter what I did it was always
something it was always something or
somebody was always trying to take
advantage of me that's a good arm that
right there that happened when they you
know came to ask you for you know
whatever assistance you can give them
that's just that's the top of it you
know that's just something that you're
just burning probably nip right now I've
been through that handsome you help
somebody and you turn around and they
demand more if you don't give them more
then they start threatening you and if
you the threats go from one day to
another I have been raped tote and total
my whole life maybe five or six times um
where I even fought back but you know
they were always bigger I was doing then
I was roped in back that and you know my
younger days and there was you know
there ain't no you know go to the police
report it you can't do it under that you
know especially when you when you're
around us stop it then I'm especially
when you're around gang
that's something that you don't do you
don't call the police and you don't do
that because it's something that they
could put a hit on you you know anything
could happen to you coming up missing
you don't ever find you again and I
definitely wasn't going to go to that so
other things happening with it when they
happen they just happened you know I
held everything inside 17 like I said
till I was 21 I stood in y8 my 21st
birthday when I thought I was going home
I wasn't the marshals were there and
picked me up they took me to the Federal
Detention Center in Terminal Island San
Pedro California where I was arraigned
and I was looking at 85 years total for
17 counts of forgery I end up doing six
I believe all together in just six years
off of that busted three or four years
that I was in why so I did like eight or
nine years straight straight without
getting out on the streets for anything
but I can say that at that young age and
going through everything that I was
going through and everything that I had
been prior to that in the younger ages I
started to learn how to adapt to the
institutional life where I can say I was
institutionalized because I didn't want
to be on the streets anymore I didn't
want to be out here or going through you
know all the things that I had went
through prior to that and I made it
comfortable I made myself comfortable in
there because I had what I wanted when I
wanted it because I was using sex to get
the things that I needed and it worked
for me
I wasn't happy but I wasn't you know
depressed and I wasn't going through all
the you know physical you know you know
all the physical damage and mental
damage that I was going through and I
learned how to work with the staff and
the staff you know they weren't bad to
me because I was who I was
so I got a lot of attention some of it
was negative like I said you know
everything's not all good some of it was
it came from the higher than just the
regular dorm stuff it actually came from
the superintendent where I drew so much
attention they you know they would lock
me in my room for one weekend to the
next weekend if I didn't you know if I
didn't agree to do with the things that
they wanted me to do which was you know
don't wear no makeup you can't do this
you can't do that and I did it anyway I
didn't care because I was being me so I
took it from one person to another well
the top of that well she befriended me
her name was um superintendent I forgot
what it was exactly but um my case
manager was Dora Baca I would never
forget her name and I would never forget
her because she was the meanest lady
that I have ever met for you know being
young you're only sixteen seventeen
years old you know you you know what
you're doing but you don't know what
you're doing you're still young you're
growing up you know you're trying to
find out who you are and she was so so
determined just to make me into a boy
when that's not who I am I'm not a boy
I'm not avoid ever having a boy I've
never played with boy things I've never
you know I've never just as a boy I've
never you know cut my hair totally off
honest I really had to because of the
burden number one that was the first
thing that you know was ever kept me
from doing trying different hairstyles
I've always that my hair growing out but
as time went on I will check you know
every couple years and sure enough
little by little with shrink though love
I think it's about this big now but it's
still there you can see it and you know
to me they'll always be this big no
matter what in my head it is because
like I said that's something that a
person don't just you know forget about
you don't forget about things like that
that scar you and that was a scar that
I'll never you know get rid of well I
went from that to go to the federal
prison and I was put into the hole as
soon as I got there lockup detention
because being transgender
let me on the yard so by their not
wanting to let me on the yard
I had a sit in there and I sat in there
for the first week where I just kept
quiet and I accepted it you know I was
in the cell by myself
nobody was bothering me so I just
accepted it you know I figured whatever
was gonna happen was gonna happen but I
started getting you know where I was
getting agitated and I was starting to
feel bottled up and I was starting to
feel too closed in because I didn't get
no you know outdoor activities that
couldn't move around it was only itself
from about right there to about the
others right there and I was in there
all that time by myself you know you
can't talk to nobody unless you can talk
to whoever's next or you well I met this
one guy he was a Cuban gardening mom
Kiki Jerome Vasquez
he ended up being my Sally how I don't
know how it happened exactly but it
happens you know they didn't want me in
the room with nobody stuffing in them
they didn't want me in the room or
nobody and they didn't know what to
expect for me because the the person
that I was I wasn't you know just a
flamboyant gay boy I wasn't you know
somebody that didn't know who I knew who
I was in they weren't comfortable with
that this head stuff were not
comfortable with that because they felt
that it was gonna cause some kind of
tension on the yard I wasn't worried
about it because I felt you know I'm
just going to be me but I didn't have no
clue of what goes on in there you know
this is federal prison is nothing like
you know being in juvenile doing hard
even went there you know it's been one
thing afternoon it like I said wow he
I'm being Cuban and coming over when he
didn't that I think but I believe it was
the 80s when they got here but I came
attached to him in the beginning in the
beginning I was attached because they
was the first guy that I've ever had a
relationship with it ever had a
relationship with a guy and telling him
he was my first relationship and I
didn't know really what prison life was
until after that with him
I remember when he um we were in the
kitchen
eating and he told me that um I was
talking or I was looking at somebody and
I didn't know what he was talking about
I really didn't I didn't know I didn't
know what he was talking about and I got
up and I left didn't mean I just didn't
care right here I wasn't gonna argue
with him you know so when he got back
into the sow he ripped my clothes off of
me he read my clothes off of me and he
slapped me in the face and then he told
me that he was they have you know all
those black guys that wanted to have me
that he was may have been come in there
and he was gonna happen rape me so I've
been born through this like I said to
have my whole life he's been something
that I just I bit down on it and I just
accepted things for the way they were he
wouldn't let me out of my cell he
wouldn't let me go nowhere my uncles and
my brother didn't know what was going on
because they were all across the yard
and that just so happened to call me for
a visit attorney visit and he didn't
want me to go he wasn't gonna let me go
my clothes were ripped off my face was
black and blue on one side and I
promised him that I was going to come
back and I wasn't gonna do try to leave
him and I wasn't gonna do nothing about
it I was just gonna keep quiet well as
soon as I got out of that cell I went
straight to my case manager my
counsellor and I told them to move me I
said I don't care worry mummy I don't
care if I go to the hole I don't care
about anything anymore I want away from
him I want out of this place
so they told me that I brought it upon
myself because they warned me that I
shouldn't have gotten this out with him
in the beginning and
they were doing it for my own protection
when they put me in there because they
knew that it was gonna happen something
like that was gonna happen
but I didn't find that it was my fault I
didn't ask for him to do that I didn't
ask for any of that so they did move him
when they called him to move by the time
I got back to the building and they were
moving him the officers told me to stay
out of my cell and let them get him out
of there
and he kept on telling me I know you did
this danger I know you did this I said
what did I do
he said I know you had me moved I said
I'm not gonna argue with you it's over I
don't want anything to do with you he
was born to get into a physical
altercation with the stuff but I guess
he had second thoughts about it figuring
that you know he wasn't gonna get
nowhere with that so he went ahead and
England to step I didn't go out to eat
to the kitchen for about a week and a
half two weeks I stood in the building
and I wouldn't leave my brother and them
came over there to see me and they asked
me what happened and I had told him some
of it but I didn't tell him all of it
because I didn't want it to blow up to
be something more because he was Cuban
and like I said my uncle's all all you
know they're all gangsters all from the
harbor area and they had told him don't
ever do nothing to me don't let them
hear or you know he was gonna pay the
consequences so I didn't tell them
everything that he did what Nana what
Mommy goomy's and I just you know I
dealt with the day by day but I wouldn't
come out because I was scared that I I
didn't know what he was gonna do I
didn't know I wasn't positive for him to
do that you know ripped my clothes off
of me and threatened me with the things
that he did and I felt that if I did if
I did say anything else I was really
gonna end up in the hole permanently boy
they don't let me out and I had years to
do still or I was gonna turn around and
you know just let him just you step on
me like the doorman one of the two but I
did not come out of that building like I
said until he came one day and he
promised that he wasn't
do that again and like I said he was my
first relationship so I was born between
feelings at that time but I was scared
to him I was young I was scared of him I
took him back they moved me to the
building that he was in but my uncle was
also in that building all I remember is
I Drake one day they made this homemade
um this homemade wine pruno and I guess
you know I must have just tilted it back
and drink the whole thing and just
everything came out of me at one time
Mannion got into an altercation my uncle
him guns on altercation I'm going to
corner the whole forearm I saw Tina on
it was either the arms the captain or
somebody but they took him when I woke
up in the morning I didn't remember any
of that that happened after I I guess I
just you know blanked out I had a
blackout I had I had abrasions above my
eyebrow I had some on my lower lip maybe
half hour after I woke up six please
came in there and they told me to pack
my stuff up I just got off the bed like
nothing and I said okay I didn't ask
where I was born and that's what the
idea I was kind of happy that I was
leaving wherever would it be better I
didn't care where and he woke up like
the devil and he said she's not going on
when she's not going nowhere
and they said sit where you're at don't
move don't move from there and sit where
you're out we're gonna have to detain
you let her get her stuff they got me
they got all my stuff together and they
put me on a bus and I ended up in
another prison they transferred me out
but on the way out that I was leaving on
the way out that I was leaving he had
cut his wrist he had cut his wrist and
you know it kind of made me not doubt
what I was feeling or what I was going
through but it made me confuse because
for him to do that to himself because
they were taking me it put me you know
in a different spot you know from what I
was thinking about him because now I'm
thinking now well maybe he cares but now
I didn't care about somebody then you
try to hurt them and you want all these
people to rape this person how do you
how can you care about this person so I
ended up in another prison where I had a
problem there too
I had the opportunity to go into an
all-female dorm or I could live with the
males I stood living with the males I
didn't want to go with the females I
didn't want to go with the women because
that was another problem so when I got
that I think that was on the yard for
maybe three weeks two months three weeks
to a month and sure enough the problems
came back to back it was one thing after
another not with the guy this time it
was with the women that were there and I
just I guess I just snapped I got to the
point where I got I got tired of
defending you know who I am
you know why I do the things I do or you
know any explaining anything about my
life period I got to that point where I
just didn't care no more so I went back
to my I went back to my room I got a
blade and I put it in the inside of my
mouth and then when I went outside I
went to the person that was harassing me
and I walked up to that person and I cut
her in her face I gave her a cut from
here to here
and then I looked at her and she said
put it down I said I coulda did that I
could I could've whipped your ass
without this raised it but I want you to
remember me I want you to remember
everything that you put me through so I
left I just walked off like nothing but
as fast as I could and I went back to my
room and I just posed of the razor
inside the toilet I flushed it maybe
five minutes ten minutes at the most
I was sitting on the yard watching
everything as it unfolded they brought
her first or her kitchen wires were all
bloody
then they turn around they came and they
somebody stand up and um put my hands
behind my back so I asked him for what I
questioned it even though I knew what I
did I questioned it and they said um
you're going to the hall for
investigation I said for what they said
you know what you did they took me to
the home they took the cuffs off of me
after they put me in the cell but when
they took the cuffs off of me I guess
they noticed the blood that was
splattering on my hand and I didn't even
know it was there but he took the cuffs
off you walked away as fast as he could
and I guess you know he figured if he
says something it's gonna mess up their
evidence which it would have I didn't
notice until after I did like this and I
seen it and I heard it and wash my hands
in the sink so when he came back he said
why did you wash your hands I seen that
blood on your hands I said what are you
talking about I denied it
i sat in them and then hold for nine
months I did in that home by myself in a
set by myself and I started you know
getting mad again you know I had anger
problems because they've everything that
I've been to so I blow up after a
certain period of time
it would just I hole everything in and
then all of a sudden you know just
whatever was going on that affected me I
let everything out so that's what I
started doing again and then they wanted
to get rid of me but they didn't know
what to do because my case was pending
still it was pending because they wanted
to give me another case for cutting that
person but they couldn't be they have no
evidence no evidence at all so the
financial around and they sent me to
Colorado the coldest place they
configured to send me and I went I went
wherever they send me I went to the hole
there as soon as I got there - they came
and they interviewed me they let me out
of the home there and as soon as I got
into the dorm again like I said I you
know prostitution wasn't new to me so I
did what I had to do
I didn't have nobody taking care of me
on the streets just just like now I have
three pitbull she's the baby out of all
of them I have two bigger ones the girls
two years old in the boys a year and
they're terrible but that's my family
that's all I got that's what that my
family is not even my real family
they're my family and I love them to
death because I know it's unconditional
love that's something that you know you
can't just take it from them you have to
earn it and I've done that I've done
that and I've learned how to deal with
people on my level because if I don't do
that and I give everybody what they want
there's not gonna be no more of me there
won't there won't be no more so I do it
on my terms now I did on my terms
all these people down here that know me
they know that I'm a good person but I
can only take so much I caught two of my
cases down here in the mid 90s my first
case I did was four years for assault
with a deadly weapon I was the victim
but they got me for it again the gyrate
mean he turned around and he wasn't
gonna let me out of his truck it was a
18-wheeler but that's when they were
going to hear a lot there was a lot of
prostitution back in those days and I
turned around stopped that Nana I turned
around and you know I can only do so
much but I defended myself the best of
my ability and he ended up getting cut
six or eight times in the face in his
chest and his legs wherever I can get
him I got him but he turned around and
he said that I was robbing him which I
wasn't I earned the money that he gave
me and he's turning around he said that
you know no she took that for me no I
didn't I earned that and then you turn
around and you raped me and you wanted
your money back and I didn't want to
give it to you so that's what happened
to turn into a physical altercation
they came maybe an hour after that had
happened and they see me coming from one
street they were looking for me actually
I'd everybody knew every like
said everybody knows me down here
including one now you know the police
said not like they used to be they were
really you know [ __ ] back then but
I've had a few that you know have been
really nice to me but it always had
something to do with sex too I always
had to do something with sex you know so
I did what I had to do like I said you
know when it comes to sex I can't even
have a normal relationship I don't know
how to have a normal relationship
because I think that everybody that's
all they want from me so I pushed people
away I push them away to a point where
I'm content in my mind knowing that I
did for the right reasons because
somehow it always ends up turning into
that that's all they want that's all
they want so I push people away
intentionally and down here downtown I
have had the most hard time that I can
say even though people don't even know I
walk around and I'm smiling and you know
people see me as a happy person that's
not who I am that's all fake its fake
it's a cover-up it's the mess that I put
on I'm not a happy person only when I'm
with Dave's most of the time when I'm
with my dogs I'm happy cuz I'm by myself
I'm in my house when I come out here if
it's not one people one person wanting
you know money for this so many I come
on I had an addiction I had a real bad
addiction I was on heroin I was on crack
I was on sure I was you name it I've
been at all I've done it all my heroin
addiction was the biggest and the worst
thing I've ever done and you know but it
kept me it kept me in my mind not caring
I didn't care I didn't care about
anything I didn't care about myself to a
certain degree but I did I cared enough
to keep myself you know my appearance up
and to do what I had to do when I had to
do it I worked with it I learned to
accept it and I've accepted it to this
day but I'm not as easy easily
influenced to you know get me alone or
to to take advantage of like I used to
be I'm not
young person the more I grew up and I
you know I had to be Who I am now
because if I don't they're gonna take
advantage of me you know like I said
I've been to to prison turns from down
here the second one was the same thing
you know it wasn't my fault I was
protecting myself and another one I
never reported I never reported none of
them you know but I got the case because
they ain't reported the guys after what
happened you know and I would stab him
then they were reporting to have to go
to the hospital but it was always my
fault I got the case the main one that I
will never forget and I ran into him
when I came down this time was this one
guy that drove no Nana
he drove a silver car I'll never forget
that man he took me to a street that's
weighed like close to I guess it would
be um Olympic probably and I didn't know
nothing about those streets back then I
didn't know none in history so I was new
out here so you know for me I was the
easy one person you know I jumped at the
cars you know one question of it you
know didn't worry about if they're
really just in the gym because I had
never really had those problems down
here I was new down here but it happens
it happened more than once and you know
I remember him putting some scissors to
my throat and him telling me you know
you gonna [ __ ] me good and you know I
said where's my money out he said I'm
not paying you [ __ ] [ __ ] you're gonna
[ __ ] me good and he I just out of reflex
my hand hit those scissors and they flew
in the back seat and I locked one of my
legs up against him and pushed him up
against the driver's door and I tried to
open the door but you know my friend and
I was locking my other net and kicking
him with the other year with the other
shoe on and I had stilettos on and I
remember that he was trying to get away
you know out of the box but he could in
my days were my legs are strong you know
and I couldn't get out he had rigged the
door the passenger door where you can't
open it like that you
and I had never been in a situation like
that before so I didn't know what to do
I was scared I panicked and I remember
just screaming and then some guy came
down the Ellen he opened the door from
the outside
he said what are you doing to her stop
it in him and then he he started cussing
at me the guy did the driver and he
tried to get out the car and I left my
person there I left one shoe in there my
nylons were ripped I was crying and I
remember running and I accepted that
after a couple hours even though I went
through all that panic and all that
stress I accepted it I came back out to
work to make my rent money and it
happened again the same day I got into a
man with this Jamaican guy and same
thing by the time he parked down here on
one of these streets on 9th Street he um
it was raining that day I did that where
I did now but it was a hotel back then
and I get over him almost I turned
around and I wasn't worried about him
because I had still on my mind fresh
from what that guy did to me hours prior
to that but when that man
parked his the armband and he turned
around you start taking his clothes off
in the front seat while I was in the
back of the van and he told me that um
same thing you're gonna [ __ ] me good or
I'm gonna kill you [ __ ] that's what he
said he was gonna kill me that's all he
had to say because I just went through
that other jail or do I turn around and
I put some silver on sheers that I had
in my backpack I pulled him out and I
went for him I just lunged for him I
just I just couldn't think I couldn't
think of nothing else I just could think
of just you know getting out of there my
safety he didn't have no clothes on he
opened the driver's door and he got out
naked and I locked it he ran around to
the other side to try to get into the
passenger side and I locked it and when
I looked down into the ignition that
keys were there and my mind just clicked
so I started it up and as I drove off I
remember turning onto 9th Street almost
flipped over because it was raining and
I went onto the curb halfway but I took
his man and I took that bat home with me
and I drove home crying when I walked
into the hotel and my manager
tell me Nana come here Mama's my manager
asked me what happened because my
clothes were open they were uneven you
know my makeup was already and I I was
hysterical because of what happened
earlier than that that's twice in one
day you know and I was thinking you know
I'm gonna get killed down here I'm gonna
get killed down here and I still didn't
pay my rent that did it yet because
those two things that happened but I was
determined as I didn't want to be on the
streets I had never lived on the streets
like you know there's Tansen step now I
hadn't did that until that Nina point I
was never on the streets as a matter of
fact you know I was scared to be on the
streets by myself because of the
situations that I had been in and the
things that was going on around me I'm
still you know I have panic attacks
still I still you know I worry about you
know the things I do I don't work the
streets as much as I used to but I still
do because you know I have to take care
of myself $221 that the GR gives you is
not enough to take care of three peoples
at myself and you know it's not because
I'm you know I'm high maintenance or I
need a lot you know things here and it
has nothing to do with none of that
because I've learned how to survive but
it's them that I worry about it's them
that I care about it's not even myself I
care more for them than I care for
myself and you know that's sad but at
the same time you know they mean a lot
to me but like I said I've learned to
adapt and I've learned to put a mask on
I do it for my own protection because if
I don't people see what I've been
through or they'll see how vulnerable
that I can be and I am very going or I
can say it honestly say that I am but
I've learned to put that mask on and it
makes me feel safer because if I don't
put that mask on I feel like you know
the worst can happen and it's not me you
know dying or anything that's not the
worst exam you know you know my dogs
what's gonna happen to them if something
happens to me nobody's gonna take care
of them like I do nobody will so I wear
that mask I walk around here but that
fake smile and you look like
everything's okay but it's not okay it's
not okay and it never will be okay I'll
never be able to recapture those years
that I lost you know have any good
memories of my childhood where I could
say I had a happy China and everybody
had a happy childhood I don't know how
to express who I really am you know
without having some part of my pasts
come and hit me in the head because I
know what I've been through I know these
people don't none of these people don't
really know what happens to me or what
happened to me or what will happen to me
if I just you know let that mask off
they don't know they don't know but I've
learned like I said to adapt I adapt to
situations as they come because if I
plan anything beforehand it won't turn
out the way that I want it it won't
something and walk up or something
there's so many people that talk to me
out here that know me but don't think
they just because they are a good person
know they've all tried to hit on me the
ones that have you know young people
that try to introduce me to you know you
I guess at one time or another
maybe not meet you but I've learned how
to just smile it off in you know push
them off little by little but you know
with sarcasm or something you know I'm
smart to stay where I'm busy or
something like that instead of opening
that door because I know once that door
is open I'm gonna lose it I will lose it
I will and it's not that I'm a real
tough person because I'm not fragile and
I know I'm fragile to a certain degree
until I feel like I'm trapped into a
corner once I'm trapped into a corner I
don't think about anything else but you
know my safety it's either me or them
and it's not even prison that worries me
anymore because it's not that it's just
I'm tired of people taking advantage of
me I'm tired of it I'm sorry people
using me for you know their own disposal
and they don't have
any kind of caring or remorse in their
heart they don't care they don't care
they don't care about the next person
and I'm just the opposite I'm opposite
than all that I help people when I can't
help them it's not because you know
easily influenced or you know I'm but
pushover it's not because it is because
even though I have been through
everything that I have I haven't lost
being human
I have anyhow lost you know the ability
to try to help somebody that I see that
you know needs it and I won't let that I
will not that I won't have to take take
over me these people that are down here
the majority of them are down here and
they got trapped down here and they
don't know anything they don't know
nothing better than to take advantage of
people or try to get over on somebody
and I told myself I would never let that
happen
I would never change like that because
that's not who I am I've had it happen
to me I've had all the words that
anybody could imagine happen to them
it's happened to me it's happened to me
but I'm here I'm a survivor I'm a
survivor and if it wasn't for I'm not
gonna send the dream because I just
thought her if it wasn't for my first
one Chloe I wouldn't be here now
she has kept me from day one from
blowing up she has kept me from going
back to prison and she has given me the
will to want to be here and to take care
of her if I don't take care of her
nobody will it should just be another
statistic out here just using her just
to get pregnant to start puppies and you
know I'm not gonna let that happen to
her I'm not gonna let nobody use her
like I've been here and I've been used
I've been used over and over and over
and over again and I've accepted it
every time until I just can't take it
anymore and I just you know push people
away so that's what I do that's me I
push people away to a certain point but
I can communicate with people at you
know the same levels they communicate
with me but I'm not a happy person and I
don't feel safe around people I don't I
have to be by myself with my dogs to
feel really
to a degree because I'm always thinking
somebody's gonna try to do something so
here we are now and you know I'm 52
years old now and my lifestyle has
changed to a certain degree but I still
can say I'm a survivor I'm not one of
the people that have fell down and
continued to wear our just disappear
into the crack so I'm not gonna let that
happen you can do it if you want to you
can you can survive you can even be on
drugs but still survive because you have
to have some kind of humanity you have
to care about yourself to a certain
degree for you to push it away little by
little but nobody knows what everybody
else goes through down here you don't
you don't know you don't know but one
thing I can say is that I am me and I
always will be me no matter what I've
been to the worst that can be but I'm
still here I'm still here yeah that's my
story
you're welcome be very welcome